maybe sticking on an evolution for a bit
because uh it's tended to create some
interesting things
uh by peter walking
do you uh why the heck did evolution
give us
i think we're are we the only mammals
that walk on two feet
no i mean there's a bunch of animals
that do it
a bit but there's a i think we are the
most successful bypass
i think some uh i think i read somewhere
that
the reason the you know evolution
made us walk on two feet is because
there's an advantage to being able to
carry food back to the tribe or
something like that
so like you can carry it's kind of this
communal
cooperative thing so like to carry stuff
back
to um to a place of shelter and so on to
share with others um do you understand
at all the value
of walking on two feet from both a
robotics and a human perspective
yeah there are some great books written
about evolution of
walking evolution of the human body i
think it's
easy though to make bad evolutionary
arguments
sure um most of them are probably bad
but
what what else can we do i mean i think
um
a lot of what dominated our evolution
probably was not
the things that worked well sort of in
the steady state
you know when things are when things are
good but but uh
for instance people talk about what we
should eat now because our ancestors
were meat eaters or whatever
oh yeah i love that yeah but probably
you know the reason that one
pre uh pre-homo sapien species versus
another
survived was not because of whether they
ate well
uh when there was lots of food but
when the ice age came you know probably
one of them happened to be in the wrong
place one of them happened to
forage a food that was okay even even
when the
glaciers came or something like that i
mean there's a million variables that
contributed and we can't
and our actually the amount of
information we're working with in
telling these stories
these evolutionary stories is uh is very
little
so yeah just like you said it seems like
if we if we study history it seems like
history turns on like
these little events that uh
that otherwise would seem meaningless
but
in the grant like when you in retrospect
were
um turning points absolutely and that
that's probably how
like somebody got hit in the head with a
rock because somebody slept with the
wrong person
back in the gay days and somebody get
angry and that turned
uh you know warring tribes combined with
the environment all those
millions of things and the meat eating
which i get a lot of criticism because i
i don't know um i don't know what your
dietary processes are like but
these days i been eating only meat
which is um there's a large community
people who say yeah probably make
evolutionary arguments and say you do a
great job there's
probably an even larger community of
people including my mom
who says it's deeply unhealthy it's
wrong but i just feel good doing it
but you're right these evolutionary
arguments can be
flawed but is there anything interesting
to pull out for um
there's a great book by the way um look
a series of books by nicholas taleb
about
fooled by randomness and black swan um
highly recommend them but
yeah they make the point nicely that
probably it was
a few random events that yes
maybe it was uh someone getting hit by a
rock as you say
uh that said do you think i don't know
how to ask this question or how to talk
about this but there's something elegant
and beautiful about
moving on two feet obviously biased
because i'm human
but from a robotics perspective too you
work with robots
on two feet is it um is it all useful to
build robots that are on two feet as
opposed to four
is there something useful about it the
most um i mean the reason i
spent a long time working on bipedal
walking was because it was hard
and it was um it challenged control
theory in ways that i thought were
important
i wouldn't have i ever tried to convince
you that
um you should start a company around
bipeds or something like this
there are people that make pretty
compelling arguments right i think the
most compelling one
is that the world is built for the human
form and if you want a robot to work in
the
world we have today then you know having
a human form is a pretty good way to go
um and there are there are places that a
biped can go that would be hard for
other form factors to go even natural
places
but you know at some point in the long
run
we'll be building our environments for
our robots probably and so maybe that
argument falls aside
you